welcome to foundations of american
democracy
this is where it all begins you might
think it's just about the united states
but here we're going to go much deeper
and much further back than that we're
going to go to the original ideas dive
into philosophy what are the rights of
the individual and what rights are they
willing to give up to a state in order
to have those individual rights
protected and this is something that
humanity has struggled with for
thousands and thousands of years but
over those thousands and thousands of
years as for the most part humanity was
controlled by kings and emperors
little ideas like democracy started
sprout up in places like ancient greece
and then in rome and all of these were
imperfect and many of us would argue
that never have they quite been
perfected just yet but it really starts
to accelerate in this part of our study
where we're going to see that the
enlightenment in europe sprouts these
questions of do we even need kings
especially when we just fought a big war
against them can we create a new type of
governance structure and what you might
not realize is the united states at its
founding was really something of an
experiment a state like the united
states did not exist in fact in the
beginning it did not even view itself as
one state or one country but a
collection of countries so as you'll go
through this journey you're going to see
it's a fascinating philosophical deep
dive into the ideas of what makes a
government function and what power
should it have and what powers should it
not have what powers should go to the
aggregate state the the united states
and what powers should go to the
individual members to the states
themselves how does a population
protect themselves from the tyranny of a
potential king or the potential dictator
in the coming lessons we're going to
dive deep into the ideals of american
democracy we're going to learn about the
debates between the groups some of whom
thought that the federal government
should have more power and others who
thought that the states should have more
power and we'll learn how it all played
out in our actual constitution how what
powers are in the hands of the federal
government what powers are the hands of
the state governments and what powers
are in the hands of both so let's start
this journey together
and to learn more about these ideas and
to get practice with immediate feedback
i encourage you to look at these lessons
on khanacademy.org